vous m
voilà c'est parce que j'ai un problème
en sortant les poubelles me suis enfermé
deux manches parce que d'autres trucs
est en panne et j'ai une clé là alors si
vous pouvez me faire la courte échelle
aux je fais exactement c'est qu'elle est
caché et je vais pouvoir aller la
chercher sérieusement avec quoi on est à
dire manche et en même temps vous désolé
ça va aller non oui je remercie je vous
embête pas ce mot chez nous ou lâché
plein
ne lâchez pas voile alors tu vois pas où
aller
oui beaucoup plus haut s'il vous plaît
regardez pas la catin oui oui ca attendu
cela trouve quoi attendez
essayez-le accès personnel à tomber je
suis maintenant je tenais à te pousse
comme pas atteint les attentes et où ses
parents